I'm unwilling to deny the existence of
free choice merely because I don't
understand it because it looks to me
like that's how people are,
that's how they expect to be treated and
that societies who structure themselves
in accordance with the idea that people
have free choice actually work now that
doesn't prove that there's free choice,
but people have been arguing about that
forever.
So,
but it looks to me.
So those are two possible means of
integration and that I think what you're
doing is feeding one or the other
constantly.
And I think you probably choose which
one to feed.
I think that's,
and I mean that's how it feels that way
to me as well.
Like when I look at my own,
you know,
maybe you're really aggravated with
something.
Maybe you're aggravated with your wife,
you know,
or,
or your child or something like that,
you know,
and you're feeling kind of nasty and
maybe even know that you're in the wrong
and an idea comes into your head.
You can think I could say that and you
know,
you could say it and you know what it
would do,
but then you pause and you think,
would that make it better or worse?
And then maybe you go to hell with it,
which is quite the thing to say.
I've got a little story about that in a
minute and then you say it,
but you knew,
you knew that you took the low road,
right,
and you know it and then you're guilty
about that and defensive and that makes
the fight way works because then there's
no damn way you're going to admit that
you actually did that and so things do
go to hell.
And so.
So here's,
here's an ugly little idea.
So that's,
that's,
that's relevant to the question.
So imagine you're playing around with
cocaine.
Now I'm using cocaine because it's very
addictive,
but it's a very interesting chemical
because it's a dopaminergic agonist.
And what,
what dopamine does is two things.
It makes you feel like what you're doing
is worthwhile,
but it also imagine that there's a bunch
of neurocircuits that are active and
then they get a hit of dopamine or you
do in those neurocircuits get a little
bit more powerful.
Okay,
so it.
It has a rewarding property which is
that it makes you feel like what you're
doing is important and it has a
reinforcing property which is.
It makes neurocircuits growth.
So now what that means is that whatever
you were doing just before you took
cocaine,
grows.
Okay?
So now imagine there's a bunch of
different things that you do just before
you take cocaine,
but there's a string of decisions and it
one decision point is the same for all
of those difference occurrences.
And that decision point is because you
know you're in trouble and that decision
point is well to hell with it.
Okay?
So then you think that each of the 200
times that you take cocaine,
even though you do it different places,
but that one thought is there all the
time and that thing grows because you're
reinforcing it and it grows and it
grows.
And it grows,
and so now that's in you,
that's part of you.
And it's the thing that says to hell
with it,
okay,
so now,
and maybe that's not such a good thing
to grow inside your brain.
So then you,
you're addicted and they take you to a
cocaine treatment center.
And after a week you're no longer
physically,
physiologically addicted.
You're not craving.
You don't have a problem as long as
you're there.
But then they take you back to your
normal environment and you see like
cocaine,
Joe,
you're a friend.
And as soon as you see him up,
that thing comes in,
Bang,
you're back on the back on the to hell
with a track and that's while you're in
will,
you're where you will end up too.
If you reinforce that particular
perspective long enough.
So that's a ken in a sense to the this
decision making process.
You know,
if you,
if you take the low road,
then that winds and it gets a little
stronger because everything that wins
neurologically gets a little stronger.
It's like a Darwinian competition.
So one rule is don't practice what you
don't want to become because you really
do become that.
It builds,
it builds itself right into your neural
architecture.
And that's one of the terrifying things
about addiction,
you know,
because you think,
well,
it's kind of psychological.
It's like,
yeah,
kind of.
It's also kind of neurophysiological and
you build a one eyed cocaine monster in
your head if you hit yourself enough
with something that reinforcing.
So yeah.
Thank you.